the country of Malawi lies in southern
Africa along the lake that bears its
name flowing south the waters of the
Shire River are used for fishing farming
and often for drinking the river is the
source of life for many villagers but
also for crocodiles once hunted almost
to extinction the Nile crocodile is now
a protected species
the crocodiles however don't extend the
same courtesy croc attacks are
commonplace along the riverbanks some
escaped with only a scar others lose a
limb many died is a problem caused not
only by the Crocs but by villagers as
well local farming and fishing remove
the crocodiles usual prey leaving them
unafraid and hungry
Solutions are not easy
the villagers tried to exercise extreme
caution when working by the river
some seek help from traditional medicine
man
conservationists have used a more modern
approach television we have what we call
drop dial safety campaigns and we tell
people how their clocks behave in water
and how they should behave to protect
themselves one long-term solution is to
build wells
a safe water supply would let villagers
conduct their daily activities away from
the river
and away from the crocodiles
but Malawi is one of the world's poorest
countries it faces many challenges
communities will have to work with
conservationists to come up with lasting
solutions until then people must depend
on the river and travel through the
realm of the crocodile